hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to talk about nutritional yeast now
you know when you think about yeast
eating yeast you probably think oh wow I
don't want to get Candida I don't want a
yeast infection but that's not what
nutritional yeast is in fact nutritional
yeast is not a Brewers used either to
make beer or bread or whatever
nutritional yeast is nutritional it's
very very different and you can consume
it it looks like this right here and
this is really amazing stuff because you
want it first of all make sure you get
the non fortified version because a lot
of times they'll add synthetic vitamins
which we don't want synthetic vitamins
we want non fortified okay but check
this out nutritional yeast has a
complete amino acid profile it's
complete protein it has all of the amino
acids and it's a vegan source so I mean
think about it you could you can eat a
steak and you can get a protein but this
is a complete protein which is very
interesting I don't know if you can eat
tremendous amounts of it it's kind of an
interesting taste but it gives you a lot
of amino acids which are building blocks
for proteins and body tissue and
hormones and neurotransmitters and a
whole bunch of other things okay number
two it gives you nearly all of the B
vitamins and that's really cool because
it's very difficult to get B vitamins
and food especially if you're not doing
grains normally when you have an
unrefined grain you get B vitamins but
we don't want to consume grains because
they turn into sugar this is a really
good source of B vitamins so B vitamin
deficiencies you creates stress it
creates the need for insulin to go up a
lack of carbohydrate metabolism a lack
of detoxification from your liver nerve
pain I mean the list goes on and on and
on nightmares so this really gives you
the B vitamins especially if you have
this stress buildup you just have a
teaspoon a day okay so it gives you the
B vitamins
it also has amazing
minerals yeah minerals like zinc
phosphorus I mean think about phosphorus
phosphorus is the accelerator of the
nervous system so if you're tired
phosphorus will actually give you energy
selenium for the immune system
molybdenum which I can't even pronounce
that but that is a mineral a trace
mineral that allows the liver to
detoxify chemicals so the stuff is
amazing so what I recommend is do a
tablespoon or a teaspoon a day I give it
to my dog my dog loves it
now the question is how do you consume
it right these just little flakes you
take a teaspoon and you just eat it okay
it gets in your teeth a little bit but
you wash it down you could mix it with
peanut butter or other things but I just
eat it directly okay so go ahead and try
this I recommend you take one teaspoon
but make sure you get the non fortified
version alright I'll see you the next
video